We love to play a quick round of-
Drewth or Dare.
(audience cheering)
And we have Charlie Gibbs (indistinct) here.
Hi, Charlie.
Hello.
You look so cute
in that bright purple.
Thank you.
That dress is popping.
I'm matching you guys.
Yeah, you are.
Oh, electric.
That's right,
we all got the memo.
Yes. (laughs)
All right, let's get down to business.
What's it gonna be, Charlie? Drewth or dare?
A Drewth.
I want to know
what's the longest either of you have ever gone
without taking a bath? (laughing)
(audience laughing)
(groans) You know
that sexy thing people have when they're like:
Ooh, they're kind of dirty and that's hot?
Yes, I do love that smell,
and I love when it gets all over a boyfriend's t-shirt
and then you can keep the t-shirt
and like just wear it and snuggle with it in bed.
Come on, you must have had that experience.
I'm good. I shower every day, you understand?
I know. Look at him.
I believe you, Ross.
Thank you. Thank you.
I, believe it or not, don't have that bad-boy musk. (laughs)
(Drew laughing)
(audience laughing)
That's what I like.
That's what you like.
It's the bad-boy musk.
Yeah. Yeah.
What about you?
How long do you go without taking a shower?
Well, here's the deal.
I can totally not wash my hair for like a week.
In fact, the natural oils,
like, rock it, a little dry shampoo,
but I can't go that long with the body.
Like, that is where I draw the line.
Like, I've gotta wash me bits, you know?
Yeah.
I gotta keep it clean.
Got it.
And then I wash
my face two to three times a day, minimum.
Understood.
So it's like the hair,
I can let that go for a week,
but the face and the body, it's a regular thing.
Yeah, but you like your guys to have a little funk-ado.
I want that bad-boy musk.
Yeah, you do.
How is that not a perfume?
Can I name a candle after that?
What? Which one funk-ado?
No, bad-boy musk.
Bad-boy musk, yeah.
Ah! That's so hot!
Yeah, that's way better.
Yeah, I'd try that candle.
By the way, I just created the perfect scent for it.
I'm gonna bring it to you tomorrow,
and you're gonna smell it.
Okay, yes. I wanna smell.
We're making candles right now,
so we're creating all these fragrances
and there's this one where I'm like,
"This is sex. It's so hot."
It's so such a turn on.
Uh-huh. And-
Oh, it's been a long time.
Yeah.
Sorry.
(audience laughing)
It's been so long
that I'm getting a little nervous standing here, actually.
She might just pounce.
Whoa. Thank you for asking this question.
(upbeat music)